i'm laura ingram this is the ingram
angle live from new york city tonight
the real accomplices that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now when the ccp sees descent building
anywhere inside china
it moves really quickly to shut it down
scrubbing all of it from their social
media such as what happened over the
weekend when more than 200 students
protested all those harsh coveted
measures that are in place at peaking
university they're brave kids
because if the offender's views are
deemed to be a danger to the communist
state a real danger
they'll be arrested and if released
their passports confiscated
well that's what they did remember to
that poor cardinal joseph zen in hong
kong
the reflex to silence opposition voices
in a totalitarian state is one thing
but now it's also the impulse of
democrats here
with the november blowout looming and
their party on the ropes they're acting
more like president xi
than president kennedy or bill clinton
their new motto seems to be
if you can't beat them
use your corporate shills to censor them
the justification is always some
horrific shooting or a protest that goes
wrong
and if the facts line up just right for
them they tagged republicans for it and
they did that of course with this
weekend's horrific attack in buffalo by
a deranged racist
social media platforms that need to be
monitored and shut down the second these
words are espoused out there in these
platforms it has to stop obviously you
have to balance the free speech issues
but freedom is so important to us but
that freedom also carries a
public safety with it and we have to
balance those
oh thanks nancy because it's always
portrayed isn't it as a noble endeavor
when the left of course wants to limit
your speech it's only a few key words
key words show up they need to be
identified someone needs to watch this
and to shut it down the second it
appears and short of that i will protect
the right to free speech but there is a
limit
perhaps she thinks i don't know we're as
stupid as her party in albany is corrupt
but we're not
the angle as always condemns all
violence and believes in the most
stringent prosecution of all violent
crimes
like the overwhelming majority of
law-abiding americans we find racial and
ethnic hatred whether white on black
black on white or chinese on taiwanese
to be repugnant under any circumstances
yet the first amendment exists to
protect speech we don't like not just
speech we agree with
only narrow exceptions to the near
absolute right to political free speech
in america such as a clear incitement to
violence for instance
if we're any different the party in
power will find any excuse to stifle
free expression in order to insulate
itself from accountability and criticism
now hulkel's thinking is so warped that
she thinks there should be limits on
speech
but none
on abortion
in fact the woman just committed 35
million dollars to urgently support her
state's abortionists
oh these people are true humanitarians
aren't they
and look we don't need to belabor the
point that these so-called liberals
never move to circumscribed expression
when the killer is a neo-marxist an
msnbc fan no no no in those cases the
carnage is the act of a disaffected lone
wolf
that killer always has complex
motivations and a hard to pin down
ideology you've read the stories
but the truth is the 2019 daytona mass
killer conor betz tweeted support for
antifa and extreme anti-police
protesters but the media
they took great pains to describe him as
just a deranged nut who was obsessed
with guns and mass shootings move right
along
yet even when buffalo authorities
confirmed that the buffalo killer was a
lone wolf
the gonzo journalists at rolling stone
say no no no no
there are accomplices here
the republicans
it's so weak i didn't want to talk about
it titus it so predictable it's so lame
because the real accomplices are in the
media the media that are propping up an
administration that has brought this
country to its knees with policies
making american families poorer every
single day
and they've tried this tax so many times
they tried to censor opposing views
during covid including ours they tried
to criminalize their political
opposition after january 6
and none of the anti-free speech tactics
ever work
eventually what happens is the truth
comes out
most of the coveted protocols were
counterproductive and highly damaging to
children we said that almost from day
one
and americans just don't think that
january 6 defines the gop
in fact most americans think that joe
biden is a complete and total disaster
on every level
think about it this way we've had the
equivalent of 20 buffalo shootings in
chicago just over the past five months
the democrats seem to care
do they look into the root causes
what to do about it not really no and no
i'd say
it's all become a political game to them
it always has been
governing matters
policy matters the economy matters
education and the border matters
and you bet crime matters too and the
democrats are 100 percent incapable of
stopping it
instead they're using the federal
government to canonize their sick
narrative and elevate their selective
concern for life
still your assessment of white
supremacist
extremists are the most lethal threat
we face in the homeland today
mr chairman
i do believe that the intelligence
reflects the fact that uh indeed that is
the case
okay
we had a hundred thousand drug overdoses
in the last year alone
it was fed largely by china and mexico
the cartels
but white supremacy is the problem to
him
if that's the case that is horrific it's
terrible
but it's weird though that when recently
pressed for specifics on this urgent
threat mayorkas came up empty
how many cases involving white
supremacists and domestic terrorists
have you referred to doj for prosecution
uh congressman let me um
simple do you not have the number it's a
simple number you've made some
profoundly inaccurate statements
no i would like the opportunity to
correct congressman i will provide you
with that information you don't know
subsequent to this hearing i do not have
so you can't name one case yet according
to a new report from the us department
of justice
almost half of all the criminals
prosecuted in federal courts in 2018
were aliens charged with crimes ranging
from drug trafficking to murder and to
kidnapping
luck the secretary of homeland security
is just not a serious person he has zero
credibility on any threat assessments
after all he presides over the massive
inhumanity and criminality taking place
every day and every night at our
southern border
democrats are losing america
including their once unshakable grip on
minorities as well
and voters know damn well
what matters most right now
it's baby food it's gasoline it's the
border it's wasted money in foreign wars
that we haven't even declared
and they want killers no matter what
their bizarre ideology prosecuted to the
fullest extent of the law
and we know now why today's liberals
love china so much don't we
because when things go bad there
they can just shut down entire cities
round up and silence political opponents
and even even make them disappear
but we're the united states of america
and we're not falling for their games of
distraction and demonization
and that's the angle